basically we took all the heaviness and
the kind of like hold it up Wow I wish I
could start at my ankles you always have
a joke but here's the thing you were
wide awake for that surgery I know what
was that like I don't even give blood
anymore you know they have to beg me and
I can't believe I did that
you know friends freaked out there oh
yeah why would you have a face like why
did your face of I said well I was busy
I wasn't doing it I thought why not I've
had so many surgeries and scars on my
body that I didn't want that I didn't
ask for and that I needed and so I
wanted to do something that was for
myself that would be positive well this
is called the Simoni facelift give me
the details how long does it take in
well dr. Simone II you know did it he's
amazing he's wonderful he's very kind
and gentle and maybe two hours really
yes in two hours I was beginning to end
from walking out the door all right
brother rolling out the door yes for
other people who want to know how much
does it cost I have no idea I think it's
maybe between 25 and 35 thousand
depending but you come out looking
beautiful you come out looking great I
didn't think I looked that bad to begin
with but apparently I did so a quarter I
would suggest it I mean I I would
suggest it it's it's non it's very
invasive but you don't have to go under
anesthesia so that's the great thing
about it for people that worried about
something happening and you know there's
so many things that can go wrong in that
hospital room when you're under
anesthesia when I had my emergency spine
surgery and I was paralyzed from the
neck down
I remember the anesthesiologist talking
to me and I said just tell me I'm gonna
see you when I wake up just tell me I'm
gonna see you and he said I can't tell
you that oh wow that is cure you know
it's scary and you've had a pretty tough
last few years um right after getting
out of jail
of course they found the tumor on your
back you had that surgery well they
could have found it a lot sooner let's
just say that okay but then after that
you had ten chemo
treatment 10 very invasive ten spinal
taps and lumbar injections right and
then you you announce that you're
cancer-free how is your recovery going
well the cancer you know it wasn't that
big of a deal I my mom died of colon
cancer my dad died of esophageal cancer
what I went through with them you know
month after month and different trials
and different you know types of chemo
and all those things
it was just utterly exhausting mine was
very quick its Burkitt lymphoma it grows
between three weeks and eight weeks it
was at about five weeks I had a pain in
my neck I went to six doctors in ten
days I went to the emergency room every
day and I got go home and take it easy
honey you'll be fine in the meantime I
had a deadly deadly right cancer in my
body
they wouldn't even do whatever thank
goodness they found it now you've been
going through physical therapy and
you're in the wheelchair tell us about
how that's going and how did how do you
feel that well it's tough I really can't
tell you why I can't walk it was the
damage that was done to my spinal cord
when the infection from the Burkitt
lymphoma was choking my spinal cord
right that's why I'm so bitter and angry
about it because if they would have
caught it just two days before I would
have walked out of the hospital but we
do have video of you attempting to walk
for the first time you shared that with
us can we watch that reward how good
does it feel to get back on your feet
and how did that feel because it's not
easy every muscle in your back your
glutes your legs your your abdominals is
contracting so hard to just take those
steps mm-hmm from the road cage to the
knees it's just loosey-goosey
that's pretty amazing I look better
standing up that's the thing listen it
is amazing and we hope that you get back
to being you again you know by the way
you went back to Dance Moms in the
wheelchair I did right now
I'm kind of out of commission from the
waist down more than ever I'm gonna be
teaching by dance vocabulary so that
when I say tombé pas de bourrée glissade
crunched a they do it and you were still
Abby Lee though well you know I can't
sit on my ass and yell at anybody that's
that's my mo but it was great it was
great to be back in the studio to do
what I do to be in my zone right and the
kids on season eight were magnificent to
work with they wanted to be there they
loved being there they grew up watching
it on television and all the sudden
their dream came true and they were in
Pittsburgh in a dance studio with me and
they learned a lot and I felt good I
forgot about the chair did you yeah and
how important is the show and the girls
and all that to you I mean clearly well
it's very important and I think it's so
educational for kids out there every
dance teacher their business has grown I
mean every kid wants private lessons
everybody wants to be like the kids on
the show competitions have grown just
because we use those competitions on the
show now I want to ask you this my dad
was a basketball coach and over the
years he softened a little bit
you're not softening yet are you no
especially I think so many parents are
soft on kids today
I think they need someone in their life
that is tough on that then holds them
accountable that expects greatness and
when I see a talented child and I know
that they can be better than they are
I'm gonna push that button and make them
better no really your own kid doesn't
know the difference no we talk for a
second because you spent time in prison
and Laurie Lachlan could be on her way
to prison because of this college
admissions scandal yeah do you have any
advice for her I think she's gonna be
fine in prison because she was on a
television show
that was with children it was a comedy
people loved it people are gonna want to
ask her questions about the show about
John Stamos they're gonna want to know
all that with me it was a little
different story the guards were who I
had the problem really what are the
problems tell me problems well just
calling me Hollywood they're supposed to
you by your last name or your number and
I was called where's the dance milady
where's the dance teacher where is she
you know just coming into your room
dumping your locker Open
taking a Cherokee red soda and dumping
it all over your clothes just for the
heck of it there it was the doctor in
the prison that took me off of all of my
medication cold turkey real all of my
diabetes and thyroid and things that you
should be weaned off of over time it was
just like this because you talk about
your issues with guards
what were those interactions like
between you and the guards did you give
them but did you give them just as much
as you got once the first two months I
was so sweet and kind and nice and I
made wonderful friends that you know I
will have forever at friendships the
next two months I demanded that they get
Heinz ketchup I and I got it there were
a couple other things that happened and
then I then I taught a dance routine for
the Christmas show and all the girls
were involved in it and it was wonderful
and their families and their children
just went crazy it was great so I got
back to my old self up by the last two
months yes I was you know correcting
grammar and saying pick up your fake
quit dragging your feet on the floor I
was screaming at everybody I was the
real Abby Lee it was tough yeah the last
two months which I know I should have
been there you know when the warden has
a meeting with you and looks at the
entire case what are you doing here I
said I don't know you tell me he said
well this would have been California you
would have gotten a letter in the mail
Wow right well here's the thing big
waste of you your attacks yes you paid
my rent for eight months in California
but you are still you no matter what
wheel chair prison wherever you are
still a believer you keep saying make up
and that's it I'm not mad at you for
that
[Music]